I think men or women God has made us
differently right so I can even speaking
to Mike
um so in Islam men can have up to four
wives
because God know who he's who he's
created men
[Music]
they're not they're not like us you know
we're maternal we're more loyal you know
that's what we want from a relationship
and that's what we bring to a
relationship whereas for men they're
more protectors providers they're more
um you know go out there and do the hard
jobs that type of thing so for them what
they want is just
to put it bluntly spread their seed and
have as many kids as they can and have
as many families as they can and I'm I
mean I I think that's fine